Marvel's Iron Fist the final season of
super-powered Netflix action until the
defenders crossover miniseries later
this year was highly anticipated by fans
of Marvel's street-level heroes and then
it actually came out fans discovered
that Danny ran superpower isn't his Iron
Fist at all rather it's the ability to
cause intense disappointment in boredom
so just what really went wrong with Iron
Fist who is Danny Rand each of the other
defenders have well-defined character
traits Matt Murdock struggles with his
Catholic guilt while dealing harshly
with the scum of the earth Jessica Jones
is an alcoholic survivor of abuse who
tries and often fails to make good
choices and Luke Cage carries the
injustice and conflict it has passed
into every situation and then there's
Danny who's only defined traits seem to
be confusion and stupidity worse his
motivations are a complete mystery even
to himself several times during the
course of the show characters ask Danny
point-blank why he abandoned his role as
the protector of the mystical city of
Kunlun in order to return to New York
and he never has an answer because he
doesn't seem to know when even the
characters don't know why they're doing
stuff it becomes pretty hard for fans to
get invested in the outcome
poor fight sequences the total lack of
character development could be forgiven
to an extent if the fight scenes were
awesome
after all fizzes iron fist fight scenes
are what Iron Fist does but instead
despite the fact that the entire show is
supposed to be about super kungfu
killers with magic powers the fight
sequences are amazing
ly boring not only does Dani almost
never actually use the iron fist his
fight scenes are consistently subpar
that's not only compared to other Marvel
Netflix shows like daredevil but even
when compared to fight scenes an iron
fist
featuring Colleen wing that suggests the
problem may lie with star fin Jones it
doesn't quite have the physical presence
pull off the whole immortal weapon bang
co-star Jessica Heimlich who plays
Colleen wing seems much better suited to
the show's brief outbursts of action
making her cage fight sequences a rare
highlight poor plotting and pacing as
underwhelming as the action can be it
would help if there were more of it or
at the very least if the plot didn't
take so long to develop the show takes
absolutely forever to get anywhere
several episodes are devoted to
boardroom strategy sessions at R and
enterprises Danny family's company
instead of the stuff that everyone came
to see mystical kung fu' action
Danny's fumbling attempts to prove his
identity dragged on and on
pouring viewers and making Danny look
like that of an idiot meanwhile most of
the stream time isn't devoted to Iron
Fist at all but rather the scheming
infighting of the family who took over
the business and absence the show
doesn't seem to know what it is or who
it's about while the show's pace picks
up a little after the first several
episodes
it never overcomes clotting problems
leaving questions big and small
unanswered and indulging and unearned
and often random but to us a
multi-episode arc that involves Danny in
the gang chasing an enemy to China for
example requires numerous logic leaps
and a severe suspension of disbelief to
make any sense at all it's not just a
poor story it's poorly told crossover
characters the characters of Gerry
Hogarth and Claire temple from previous
Netflix series those have supporting
roles and they immediately class up any
senior end but this actually does the
show no favors because he'll Garth
steely charisma and temples reluctant
heroism nicely illustrate the lack of
defined character traits for the main
cast they serve as in for
reminders of better written shows I
really didn't realize who's going to be
so much emotional honesty right and
while Claire standin see to point out
the story's plot holes as the crop up
injected those of humor into a series
that takes self way too seriously it
also highlights the show's shortcomings
while making Claire seem like a visitor
from a totally different much better
series which she totally is have you
stopped to consider that this idea
totally sucks it doesn't suck okay kind
of harsh Claire not really moral
confusion as we're constantly reminded
throughout the series
Danny was raised to be the iron fist the
immortal weapon his job is to defend
Kunlun from the hand to villainous group
of ninja assassins who plague daredevil
on his show as well
despite being trained from childhood to
destroy the hand wherever he finds them
Danny finds himself morally conflicted
several times over whether to kill his
enemies that's nice but it doesn't feel
organic to the character at all it feels
like a moral conundrum forced onto Danny
by writers confused over how to inject
eternal drama into a character they
don't have a real handle on the
diversity problem somewhere in iron
fists is the potential for an
interesting discourse about privilege
that conversation never actually happens
on the show though and it's too bad
because it desperately needs it Danny
comes off as beyond entitled using his
wealth status and family name as a
bigger weapon than his magic fist and
with even less thought that in and of
itself might not have been an
insurmountable problem given that the
most popular character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Tony Stark is also a
rich white jerk what did I tell you
would happen if you ate glass doughnuts
great white blue sprinkles little foggy
on it but I think it was something like
raining down the Hellfire but Stark is
self-aware he knows he's a jerk that's
why we love it can you feel that we're
done here move out the way I'm going to
run you over
I could Danny Rand on the other hand is
not self-aware at all and let's also
consider the fact that much of the
show's free release buzz centered on
questions about cultural appropriation
and whitewashing since Marvel decided to
cast a white actor in the role of an
Asian Savior figure the series needed to
address those
shoes instead of making worse that first
big casting misfire most fans would
agree that Marvel Studios has an
unbelievable track record with is
casting a major characters from Robert
Downey jr. is complete embodiment of
Tony Stark to Tom Hollands pitch-perfect
Peter Parker
they've been remarkably sure-handed and
the Netflix series has been no exception
until now unfortunately the early
skepticism of Jones casting turned out
to be well warranted he may be a fine
actor but he was woefully miscast in
this role there's never an onscreen
moment that truly feels like the iron
fist from the comics except for one very
brief scene in which danny has shown old
film footage of a previous and much
cooler iron fist in action whoever that
dude was we love to have seen more of
him and more of that kind of frenetic
flood kicking action instead of the
soggy mess we got still there's reason
to hope that the defenders can right the
ship showrunners Marco Ramirez and
Douglas Petrie called the shots on
daredevil second season and there's
plenty of opportunity for Danny's
character to grow within the dynamic of
his team of super buddies perhaps we'll
see a more disciplined take on the
immortal iron fist when the eighth
episode defender series makes its way to
Netflix thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]